hi there Steve here Steve Kaufman today
I want to talk about grammar and grammar
books now many of you who follow me here
oh and by the way if you enjoyed these
videos please subscribe you know that I
tend to de-emphasize grammar and in fact
one of the reasons I learned Russian was
to show that you can learn Russian even
if you don't focus totally on trying to
master the grammar I feel that they put
grammar up front and that this is an
obstacle because until you have had lots
of exposure to the language it's really
hard to make sense of the grammar
explanations to remember the
explanations and the rules and so forth
and so on
however that doesn't mean that I don't
use grammar books or grammar resources I
do so today I want to talk a little bit
about grammar books I like to perhaps go
to them initially to have a bit of a
leap through normally I'll get that
amount of exposure to grammar in a
starter book teach yourself or whatever
but I don't try to remember anything I
don't try to understand it too much I
certainly don't do the exercises and
then at various stages I refer again to
grammar so you can refer to grammar on
google you can look things up conjugate
this verb in french or whatever but
there is a series of grammar books that
I find very good I've mentioned them
before and this is the dover series all
right German you know when I go to learn
Dutch I will consult this because it's
short you want to be able to get in and
out of your grammar book you don't want
a great lengthy grammar book the only
exception would be if you were at a
later stage doing the grammar in the
language in which case you're also you
know learning new words and being
engaged with the language
another good series is these verbs and
essentials of grammar again they're very
very thin and verbs are so key to any
language I find that we have to we have
to get very good at the most common
verbs in the language so spending a
certain amount of time with verbs
even though every time we look at the
conjugation table the subjunctive
imperfect we forget it all this day I
have never been able to remember
but I think it's just one of these
things that washes over you and helps
you notice things makes you more
conscious of things when you're in the
language so I think the key with a
grammar book and I should say that it's
not just books I have been able to find
free grammar resources on the internet
PDF files I've mentioned before this
wonderful Romanian grammar resource that
I found on the internet and downloaded
super which I even you know was able to
move as a PDF file into my Kindle so I
can read it on my Kindle I can read it
on my iPad what distinguishes good
grammar books is they are light on the
explanation they don't try to account
for every possible situation in the
language you are going to discover a lot
of that yourself if you get enough
exposure it has to just kind of just
touch on some of the highlights mention
a few examples that sort of stimulates
you to be aware of certain things that
you might otherwise not be aware of and
and so touch on the main things and that
can be done as I say in relatively thin
volumes like this this and that's what
you should look for you should avoid in
my opinion grammar books so where
there's too much explanation
every possible exception is explained
you should also avoid grammar books
where there are too many exercises
simulated roleplay you know connect the
dots any of that stuff it just fills up
room in the grammar book the grammar
book in other words where I want to
engage with the language is in authentic
situations reading something of interest
to context that makes sense
speaking about a subject of interest I
don't want artificial roleplay I don't
want some artificial questions I don't
want some artificial examples I was
reading living language and it has
something about birds nests or something
like that I got worms nest I can do what
birds nests for quite a long time it's
not that big in interest of mine so you
want to go to grammar books which have a
small amount of explanation a few
examples
you know if possible no exercises or
drills just the essence a sort of an
overview of what takes place in the
language because if you can learn
everything that's in one of these little
books by frequently referring back to it
and looking for it in your reading and
noticing it in your listening if you
know this and you don't know you know
you don't know this you know this is all
you need you're gonna you're never gonna
be perfect
so my suggestion on grammar books is
keep them short focus on the basics some
key rules and examples and refer to them
from time to time and you do need them
that's been my experience okay thanks
for listening
[Music]